police are still on the lookout for what
sources are calling the uber killer the
serial murderer uses the popular ride
share service to isolate victims
authorities are encouraging extreme
caution when using the ride share
application call for an uber yep can you
help me with my bag
so what you got in that little bag of
yours anyway oh not much
just some clothes I was hoping to have
room for some souvenirs on the way back
what nothing
you can actually go straight here don't
worry hon a shortcut
I I needed get out relax sweetheart I
really just pull over
as you wish
authorities are encouraging extreme
caution for drivers using the service in
the area especially in the late hours of
the night
they also recommend working with a buddy
remember the uber killer could be anyone
thanks for watching
uber horror we were wondering when
you're riding these things do you Elise
it in the front or the back let us know
in the comments if you like this video
be sure to like this video and subscribe
for new Horrors every month and if you
like the voice in the radio check out
let's read channel he does horror
narrations lists and creepypasta if you
want some more horror films check out
this playlist and we'll see you in the
next video assuming we survive